Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new harry potter video they just announced
that there's going to be a harry potter series on
hbo warner brothers is working on so i'll explain
what's going on what they've said about it so far
and where it would probably fit into the timeline
of the wizarding world in the harry potter movies
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i will do episode videos
for when it eventually releases on hbo max but
based on what they've said about their actual
development of the project i'll explain when i
think they'll actually release episodes the funny
thing is that warner brothers themselves actually
said that they're starting development but also
that there are no series in development basically
in the same breath which i think is basically them
trying to lie in cover because they're not ready
to start talking about it yet but you read between
the lines i think it's very clear that they're
definitely developing harry potter tv series when
it comes to studios commenting about projects and
things like this especially the really big stuff
you need to learn that people in hollywood lie
all the time lie about everything and usually it's
the studio putting pressure on them to lie about
it so that they don't give away any big spoilers
or reveal anything before the studio wants to
reveal things the hollywood reporter who was
reporting this news are actually very reputable
they're usually very accurate about stuff like
this so if they say there's smoke then there's
definitely a fire but i think when most of you
probably saw this news this morning you probably
were not surprised there are so many big shows
that are in development right now big-ip like the
new big budget dc series that are coming to hbo
max the three new game of thrones prequels that
they announced a while ago and hbo max has not
been doing so well that's why they have their big
2021 movies planned to release all of their new
movies on hbo max simultaneously at the same time
as they do in theaters they want to be able to
compete with netflix all the programming that they
have coming disney plus and all the big marvel and
star wars series that they have coming down the
pipeline the next few years so harry potter and
the wizarding world franchise is one of the most
popular things that they own it was only a matter
of time before they reached into that sorting hat
to pull out some tv shows they still are doing
the fantastic beasts sequel movies right now
there have been rumors that after those they may
eventually reboot the original harry potter movies
or bring the original cast back for direct sequels
to the original movies because every year people
ask the original cast daniel radcliffe emma watson
rupert grint are you going to come back as the og
team for more new harry potter rupert grant so far
has been the only one who's like yes definitely i
will totally come back for more harry potter
in the future daniel radcliffe is kind of on
the fence the way he talks about it he says that
he's totally fine with them completely rebooting
the franchise but then also maybe someday he'll
eventually come back and do more harry potter
but he's not in a huge rush to do that and emma
watson has also kind of said similar things like
i'm working on a bunch of other projects so she's
not rushing to come back and do more harry potter
but based on the timeline of the fantastic beasts
movie right now if they wind up bringing the cast
back or rebooting the movie franchise that
wouldn't happen for like seven or eight more
years so that's so far off in the distance that
you don't even need to worry about that right now
which is where all the tv shows come in that
they're developing there is also that harry potter
and the cursed child stage play which is sort of
like another direction that they've expanded the
universe and is a sequel series to the original
movies so i'll explain that during this too
but i think all this harry potter universe movies
tv shows makes more sense when you hear that
warner brothers just named their own kevin feige
person is an overseer for all the harry potter
franchise related projects that includes any of
the new movies that they do the fantastic beasts
movies any other prequels or sequel movies they
do in the harry potter universe fantastic beasts
was really just the start of that and any new tv
projects that they spin off as well they haven't
officially confirmed exactly when this first new
series would take place and which characters it
would follow they've only said that they've just
started meeting with people taking pitches and the
strongest concept is going to win out but i think
the idea is that they wouldn't just reboot the
plot of the original movies straight up so we're
probably not going to see them cover the events of
the main books if they did that like i said they'd
probably wait for a movie series reboot in seven
or eight years just reading all the different
news announcements that the outlets are putting
out about this project it sounds more like they're
taking the lord of the rings approach with it the
past couple of years if you haven't been following
the news amazon and warner brothers spent over a
billion dollars to get the rights to the lord of
the rings tv series that's right warner brothers
had the rights to the movies doing a lord of the
rings tv series apparently way more expensive for
them but because the movies were so good and still
so popular they didn't want to just redo the plot
of the movies with the tv show so the lord of the
rings tv series is a prequel set during the second
age of middle earth and is going to follow sauron
as he creates the rings of power sauron when he
looked like this so the harry potter people at
warner brothers have a billion different prequels
to pick from that they could do and still tie very
closely to the events of the movies but just given
their restrictions here are my top picks for what
that would be just starting with the very obvious
story of the founding of hogwarts like hogwarts
year one it be said almost a thousand years ago
with godric gryffindor salazar slytherin helga
hufflepuff and roryno ravenclaw coming together
putting aside their differences temporarily at
least to build the school itself and just follow
them in the first years of them running the school
there's only some of hogwarts early history that's
been well documented but there's enough canon that
they wouldn't have to just make everything up out
of thin air to contradict later facts established
in the main books that's usually the danger with
any big prequel series for books that haven't
completely been written yet they haven't really
said much about jk rowling's involvement since
she could also expand as much of the history
of the universe and characters as they would need
to actually turn something into a full series
and that's true for any story that they go with
but she's kind of a controversial figure right
now so i don't know how much fans want her to
be involved with the material and it's not like
a george r martin situation with the game of
thrones franchise in the prequels that hbo is
currently doing even though he writes as slowly as
possible and we will probably never see the full
completion of a song of ice and fire novel series
fingers still crossed for winds of winter released
next year though he still has a pretty decent
relationship with the fandom and with warner
brothers and hbo brass and he's very much involved
with helping them plot out the story of the game
of thrones history for their prequels just to make
sure that they don't mess too much of that history
up the reason why they created hogwarts in the
first place is because at that time in history
wizards and witches were being heavily persecuted
by society and they wanted to create a secret
place for them to learn the craft of magic so they
built hogwarts in the scottish highlands and threw
up enchantments around it to prevent muggles from
discovering it the four of them worked together
for a little while at least until their infamous
falling out over exactly what and who they should
be teaching at hogwarts that's all covered in the
backstory that they give you in the harry potter
movies and books but it's a really easy slam dunk
and it's set far enough in history that it would
be a lot easier for them to tell that story they
would run into fewer issues with contradicting the
timeline and keeping things in continuity than
they would if they did a series in present day
the next big prequel series that a lot of the
fandom has been talking about for a long time
is just a straight-up marauder series about
harry's father and his friends creating the secret
club and the adventures that they have during
their school years in the 1970s if it wasn't clear
or you didn't read the original books harry potter
starts year one at hogwarts in the early 90s not
the early 2000s the movies kind of blurred this a
little bit shifting things forward in the timeline
closer to the present day of when the movies were
actually being released in those early 2000s so
that's why some of the technology that they see in
the real world seems like early 2000s technology
and not 1990s technology i think as long as
they're consistent with the time setting of
the events of the original movies anything that
they do with the prequel series will be fine
there have been a lot of people since the news
was announced that have been asking for a young
severus snape series people have been fan casting
adam driver but i don't know how up he is for
doing a harry potter tv series but i do like the
idea of a young severus snape series about his
later time in school in his early years in the
death eaters and then falling in with the events
of how he started working as a double agent for
dumbledore so day one it would also just be way
easier to do his story than for another character
in the last really big idea would be for them to
do something with either a younger voldemort
during his school years and early years after
leaving hogwarts creating the horcruxes looking
for the deathly hallows like a death eaters series
which would be a darker spin don't know if they
would want to do that if they want to do something
that's a little more family friendly or they just
do a bigger version of harry potter in the cursed
child the only thing about cursed child is
that it's one of those more recent jk rowling's
additions to the canon that fans either love or
they hate because of how it addresses some of the
events of the original books and movies it's one
of those series that sort of retells some of the
plot of the original story and changes some things
so it's easy to see why some fans didn't like that
story like why are you messing with this original
story it was already perfect why do you have to
trample on it if you never saw the cursed child
play or read the story it set 19 years after the
events of the deathly hallows and harry potter has
since become the head of the department of magical
law enforcement of the ministry of magic in his
younger son named albus severus potter is getting
ready to start his first year at hogwarts he was
named after dumbledore and snape it's literally
the deathly hallows ending scene of them showing
up at platform nine and three quarters where you
see all of them older the older son that they have
there next to him is named james sirius potter
so they just send him off to his first year at
hogwarts and that's where the events of cursed
child play out the story itself winds up twisting
a lot of the conventions of the original harry
potter books where harry's son winds up becoming
good friends with draco malfoy's son instead of
becoming enemies his name was scorpius and then
albus severus winds up shocking everyone when he
gets sorted by the hat into slytherin's house you
can imagine the heart attack that it gave harry
he and scorpius wind up getting into all kinds of
trouble using this special prototype super time
turner to mess with historical events in the
harry potter universe and it winds up crossing
over and making some big changes to the night that
voldemort killed harry's parents and marked him as
the final horcrux so it's very controversial
either way and i think that warner brothers
is going to try and avoid altering any of the
pre-existing cannon as much as possible which is
why it's more likely that if they go the prequel
route they'll just steer clear of recent history
but based on their timeline for development like
they just started working on the series right now
it'd probably be at least like three years before
we see any kind of footage or a trailer or they
start filming and casting i will do another video
about it when we get more concrete details and as
long as the series is good i will do episode
videos for it but obviously i'll be doing
episode videos for the lord of the rings series on
amazon all the game of thrones prequels the marvel
star wars disney plus series and all the dc hbo
series but everyone click here for my brand new
Wandavision episode 3 video in marvel easter eggs
and click here for that brand new godzilla vs kong
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!